and today we will just go over the
social media foundations and the
different social media media channels
that are available to you
so the first one and one of the most
popular
and overlooked social media
channels are blogs
the reason that blogs are typically
overlooked is because there's a
misconception
of how blogs are effective because of
the new trend with social media
networking sites such as pinterest
such as facebook youtube
instagram
snapchat
linkedin
twitter
because these social media networks
allow you to interact with people and so
when they started becoming popular
people mainly marketers
and internet marketers saw that as a
chance to
keep their post
up to date and to
connect with their audience instead of
through a blog
but the benefit of having a blog is that
first of all it's your home on internet
if you are doing business online
you need you should have a blog because
it's where you produce content is how
you you're following the search engines
is how you establish your bra your brand
your blog is like your home and social
media networking sites are like places
that you go hang out or like family
members houses
um you know like grandma's house growing
up it's like you're sarah you're home so
that's not like what facebook is
and
they differ as i mentioned
and the misconception also lies with
the purpose of blog so you know what
let's get into it
let's understand the landscape
people congregate and connect on
different social media channels
they use these channels to engage with
people and as a touch point before
drawing them to interact with you on
your website blog microsite or other
channels
so as i mentioned some of the big sites
are
pinterest blogger youtube facebook and
twitter
you create an integrated approach so
that all your channels can work together
and you can lead people from one channel
to another which is kind of considered
like bouncing so they're bouncing from
different networks just to connect with
you
you can move people from social media to
own medium which is more so your blog
and this enables you to interact
effectively
this enables you to interact effectively
with your target audience
so let's just do a brief introduction to
blogs
a blog can be decentralized housing for
all your content marketing efforts
your blog can be the hub where all your
contact redirects engaging viewers at a
deeper level
the benefits of using a blog as a home
base are as follows
constant link building
which helps you be found in the search
engines
serve as resource for users
as it is an archive of information
product soft selling is also
possible you have topic based content
provides topical links
and you have shareable content
as well as being able to engage with
your fans on your home base
an average website with a blog has 55
more visitors than a site without a blog
a site with blogs get 97 more inbound
links
and blog based websites you usually have
434 percent more indexed
pages than non-blog sites
blogs can help you reach the audience at
the right level
so let me just kind of break this down
and explain it to you
so
a website is
web 1.0 where a blog would be like web
2.0 when websites became popular for
business usage it was a place to
basically advertise
your business online so
instead of passing out brochures you
like hey go to my website you get the
information here
or
instead of sending out
circulars you're like hey check out my
website i have this myself
now what blogging has done
blogging has
made content marketing a digital concept
content marketing actually the old
concept and it goes back to i'm gonna
say 1896 with john derry when he
produced the first magazine pharaoh for
marketers
and that magazine today has sell
millions of cop copies worldwide and is
still very strong in the farming
industry
so
with blogs
they allow you to picture content on
your website now
although today's topic is about the
foundation of social media we can't
escape the concept of content marketing
not even a concept the strategy the
techniques of content marketing which is
also an overlooked product and just for
future reference simply learn we offer
courses on content marketing to give you
a better understanding of how content
marketing interacts with digital
marketing but i'm just going to give you
a brief synopsis real quick while i have
you on this training so content
marketing is the intersection between
um
publicizing and advertising so let me
break that down a little bit further for
you when you look at a magazine looking
at a journal article
or a newspaper
tv
radio what happens is you have the
content rather it is a visual which is a
imagery picture
audio which is something that you listen
to such as the radio
um
or tv which is a combination of um
audio and visual because on tv you're
looking at it they are they share the
content and then they run advertisements
and with
these advertisements are considered
commercials and the reason that most
businesses prior to the internet
did not engage in this type of marketing
was because it was very expensive and
what the
blogging strategy has done how it has
revolutionized the digital marketing era
is that blogs are your home to
um
produce your content and advertise your
products
and that's it that's the power of a blog
and that's why blogs have 55 more
visitors as cyber cyberblogs get 97 more
inbound links and what that means is
that
if you're actually writing a good blog
post and you are
syndicating the blog post that means
that you are distributing your blog
blog post across different social media
channels which means that you're driving
traffic back to your home okay
that's the kind that's that's that's the
purpose of social media
sites to get traffic to go somewhere and
you want them people to go
to your blog and the more that you send
it the more blog posts that you have the
more you syndicate the more imbalance
that you get because you have people
coming to you from different sites and
the the key to it
is tracking to find out where they're
coming from a blog-based website usually
have 434 percent more indexed pages than
than non-blog based sites
so let's get back to what that means the
reason that blogs have more indexed
pages is because you can produce as much
content as you want on your blog
the more content you create the more
pages that you have the more content
that you create the more pages you have
the more likely that you're going to be
found in the search engines
so when people are people doing searches
for keywords in your your market if
you're blogging about that you they can
find your blog post and go to your
website
and blogs can help you reach the right
audience at the right time
that is so true but the key to the key
to it is writing writing and producing
good quality content and syndicating our
content and make making sure that you
are
networking with your audience
now before you blog you need to consider
who your audience is what they are
looking for and the best way to reach
them
the purpose of your campaign
the goals you are trying to accomplish
through your blog content as well as
how will you measure your success the
metrics or make checkpoints through
analytics
and whether your plans are sustainable
or not
so who is your who your audience is what
they are looking for the best way to
reach them that is the key
to having an effective blog because if
you don't know who you're writing for or
two
and if you don't know what they're
searching for and you don't know how to
reach them
the blogging is pointless
the beauty of
social media
is that you are able to connect with
your target market but ha
the question too is my friend is that
you have to figure out who your target
marketing is
and once you figure out who your target
marketing is talk the market is and
you're talking the audience is you know
we can go look for them
and
then you can
strategically plan out a way to reach
them
so
the next two goals can't having setting
goals and knowing your purpose you can't
just aimlessly say oh i'm gonna have a
blog you know you don't have any
direction like you're not gonna get in
your car and drive down the street and
not know where you're going
so
you have to treat your blog just the
same way your blog is your employee so
you have to train it that way you have
to
make sure that
it's doing its job effectively and it
has a clear purpose
so on simply learn
we talk
about
different
skills and trades that you can use to
enhance your professional career and we
provide trainings on that and so our
our content is related to that so one of
our contents
one of our topics that we talk about is
digital marketing so
before i started this webinar i had a
plan of my content of what i'm sharing
with and i have a plan of who i'm going
to
reach out to show this video to
now
you can't start something without having
you can't start any phrase
you cannot start a
goal
without knowing how to measure your
success or what matrix of measurement
points to it through analytics to use
now i'm not going to get into this but
i'm and i'm going to let you know that
the beauty of digital marketing
and the beauty of social media
mark um
the beauty
of
social media
is that you're able to measure and track
different
points of your content and where your
blog is concerned you can track the
number of visitors you can track where
your visitors are coming from you can
track how long they're staying on your
page you can track to see what is
generating the most traffic so you can
you can know how to use that content in
other ways
and
there are so many
other
matrices that you can
learn about which we will discuss in
another topic so i really hope that you
subscribe to our youtube channel
that you can stay abreast of our new
trainings
the 80 20 rule for blog visitors
now
people believe that high traffic to a
blog means
many repeat visitors
but
in reality and seriously i really hate
to break your bubble
only 20 of your blog's
visitors are going to come back on a
regular basis which means that the
remaining 80 of
visitors are first-time visitors
that means that
of the people
that see your blog on a regular basis
come back
and 80
of the visitors
are just
coming to your site for the first time
so what you want to do
is to circumvent
the 2080 rule
so you can maybe have it switched
reverse it meaning that
most of your blog visitors
or your blog loyalists or your loyal fan
base
you incorporate
a conversion marketing funnel with an
email marketing campaign
and let me explain what that does
when you enter
something called a call to action at the
end of your blog post
that means that you are directing your
reader to do something
so
when you have a blog and you're writing
about a topic you should have something
called a marketing campaign
that
goes along with
the blog post and let me explain in
simple terms what i mean by that
your content
should be aligned to the product that
you're selling
so
end of your blog post you can sell you
up your product and this is how you
subliminally sell
through
blogging
if you're doing it effectively
because
first time visitors they only provide an
opportunity
to connect
to a new audience when people come to
your blog where you want them to stay
another thing that you can also add and
again this is top notch info
you can add a pop-up ad or
a welcome mat or something that visitors
have to enter their information to see
your blog post
but we can go more in detail in that
once you join the simply learn
training the simply learn
by joining this simply learn digital
marketing trainer that's coming up
and
hey guess what i will be your trainer so
i will have all types of getting to you
with blogs it's easier to educate and
motivate the audience than with other
social media channels so let me explain
you you have your blog post right and
you have a social media channel so your
social media channel is where you say
hey you know check out this blog post on
this topic
and you share the link which is as i
mentioned in a few slides back that's
called inbound linking because you're um
you're you're spreading
your content across the web and what
social media does it allows you to
create
and platforms different social media
channels so you can connect with your
different audiences
and you send them to your blog post that
goes to your blog
um and the cool thing that you do
as i mentioned you want to you want to
capture the 80 of those visitors that's
coming to your blog
you have a welcome mat
and that's a very strong
smart
marketing move and you can also add
something called a retargeting pixel if
you're
using facebook or google i love facebook
facebook is my baby
that's my go-to social media set it's my
second home from the internet and
in the future trainings we will
we will um talk more about that so make
sure that you subscribe to our blog and
that you click the link below so you can
get more information about
my upcoming training on simply learn
so
five essential skills you need for
blogging see
this is this is what
disturbs me
about bloggers
because
when you most people when they start a
business or they're
especially online they're thinking that
oh i could just do what
everybody else is doing you know
socially and personally on social media
no baby that is not the case there are
rules there are strategies there are
techniques that you have to incorporate
in order to be
successful
and effective in your
your marketing efforts
so
five essential skills you need to know
for blogging how to write content
content
comes in four types of formats
text
audio
video and image
and a good content writer
will learn how to incorporate all four
of those or three or four of those
um i am big on
text images and videos i haven't
i haven't ventured into the audio world
yet but i do plan on starting a podcast
for one of my brands
i'm thinking about it it's starting to
sound like really intriguing to me so i
don't know we'll see but if you want to
find out make sure you join me for my
training because i'll be sharing all
these all my
goodies for you
i'm want to engage
that's important like
you can't just have
you can't just write a bull crap
article
it has to be engaging because
when you produce good content the
content produces
an audience which produces revenue for
you that's how you make money off of
blogging you have to you have to follow
a chain
and as i mentioned um when you're
writing content just to go back to that
remember
your con when you're producing content
it should be an intersection between
your content and
advertising and you know you advertise
your products or whatever
whatever affiliate companies that you're
with you just make sure that it's
relevant to that particular blog post
and how to keep the golden focus if you
don't have a goal you don't know where
you're going there's no point of it
because you're just going to be
aimlessly writing with no direction
and when a lot of people start
in this
arena they don't have a goal in mind
they're just like oh let me produce
content no
your content has a job baby and if you
don't do that
if you don't train your content to do
his job is ineffective
and when you are an ineffective employee
you get fired
and you get somebody to come and hire
someone that is effective
so you want to make sure that you are
training your content correctly and we
talk about that and the upcoming digital
marketing certificate associate training
will simply learn
that i will be teaching
and you want to understand the basics of
seo seo another concept that most people
do wrong
okay
the basics of seo search engine
optimization
now
i'm going against the green but i'm just
i'm sharing from my experience
if you effectively
use
if you effectively effectively use seo
in your blog post there is no reason
that you need to pay for adwords because
people run adwords to get their drive
traffic to their content but there are
organic strategies that you can use seo
wise to be found on the first page of
google so you can
invest your
digital advertising budget in a more
effective manner that's going to
actually generate the traffic
that you want but that's more advanced
than that like i say i have a training
coming up and if you want to know that
information make sure you register for
my training
and the basics of pr
the basics of public relation it's
basically syndicating your content
getting out there talking to people and
letting the world know who you are
which is also a
pr and branding to go hand-in-hand
build a content plan
there's going to be a treat for you
okay
there's a treat
for every participant that joins my my
training they're going to get a content
plan
and
maybe just maybe
you'll be able to get a content plan
sooner than that just so you can get a
feel of what we're doing
but
if i do the link will be below
so once you decide where you want your
want to
house your content online build a
content plan and let me explain to you
by that
in order to produce content online you
need something called a content
management system
and there are many out there you have
wordpress blogger wix
other google blog um
you have a lot of pay blogs
my preference might go to is wordpress
wordpress is awesome
um i can share with you my wordpress i
just finished my site so i haven't
started blogging yet which i am going to
start
this week
like i said i just finished my blog so
let me just show you
it is empty
so i designed this this is my website
build your dream business online
i am an online business developer
and this little button right here is my
news button and this little button right
here is going to house all my um content
i just click like i said it's built my
new blog so
i haven't started blogging yet but i
will but when i do this i will have my
blog here
i want to delete this part out i'm sorry
i don't like that because it's not it's
not done
so let's start over build a content plan
once you decide where you want to house
your content online you build a content
plan
when you're housing your content online
you use something called a content
management system
and a content management system that i
prefer is wordpress but you have others
you have list blogger the
the google tumblr and you also have a
lot of paid blogs but me personally i
prefer wordpress
because
wordpress
has a lot of has the most functionality
and i'm not going to get into that
because
i'm not talking about web development
but we do offer a web development course
as simply learn
and so if there's something you're
interested in learning about make sure
you click the simply learn link
below and you subscribe to our videos
because we will also have
um web designs trainings on here as well
just not for me because that's not my
area of expertise but um yeah you need
to have a plan if you don't have a plan
for your content you don't know where
you're going you just aim the writing
content and
it's pointless
the use of an editorial calendar
you use an editorial calendar to make
you know of the events that
your business
is promoting
or your online community
the keywords to be targeted such as
by your seo team
you want to have
holidays that are relevant to your brand
or service because
believe it or not rather you like
rather or not you believe in holidays
the people that are going to buy from
you they do so you have to stay in line
with that because what you're doing your
business is about the people that you're
serving your target audience the target
market that you're serving
and you have to treat them how they're
used to be treated
marketing
is
relationships
and if you don't nurture their
relationship
you're not going to get any
and you also have to have a call to
action as i was mentioning before
and i said that um
maybe i didn't i don't remember
so let me just tell you what a con call
to action is a call to action is a
is a command you remember in english
class when you um you learned about
different types of sentences and when
the type of sentences that you learned
were a command
and
that command say hey click this
link to do here or click the subscribe
channel to assembly learns youtube
channels so you can get updated
information of our trainings
or click the link below to get
an example content plan it's a call to
action something engaging for people to
do but if you don't tell them what to do
they're not gonna do it if you tell them
to do it
most of them will everybody's not gonna
do it but you have a good amount of
people that will you have the people
that want more information about your
upcoming somebody learn training
they will click the link
because they want the training
and that's my call to action
you use this guide to create a plan of
the content you want to share and when
you want to share it and another thing
that's not only that i do
i know where i'm syndicating my content
at
because
you have to syndicate it there's no way
around it
you build a content plan
so
your content plan is an editorial
calendar for
your content
you first
gather search phrases to guide the focus
of content on the blog so you want to
use something called long tail keywords
which are phrases instead of just
short-term keywords so whatever your
industry is in you um you focus on that
you focus on first you not focus on that
let me let me be clear honestly the
first thing that you need to do in your
content plan
is once you identify your market you
write down topics on your market that
will interest people or people would go
to google and ask google questions for
so once you write down that list
brainstorm or what type of questions
people will ask and then you go to the
google keyword planner
and
you um
you know what let's just do that let's
do a quick overview real quick
let me do a quick um search with you
let me show you real quick
what this looks like
oh sorry so i'm opening up my my keyword
okay this is not what i want
okay
maybe we'll just edit that out too
i don't like um
sorry i just wasn't prepared for that
oh
hold up sorry
all right let's go back here
so building let me start this slide over
over building a content plan
when you're building a content plan you
create an editorial calendar for
building your content plan
which starts with
gathering the search phrases who got the
focus of your content on log now this is
what i do and i'll talk more about this
in my training
and and give you
more handouts
gather the search phrases to guide the
focus of your content law you don't want
to use short-term keywords such as one
or two words you want to use long-term
keywords such as phrases so the first
thing that you do is that you write you
write down topics that people will be
interested
in in your market and then you write out
phrases or questions that people can
people will go to google and search
about and then there are different
strategies that you can use which i
teach which i will be teaching in an
upcoming course about how to use your
google um
analytics to do that
um
not google analytics i'm sorry your
google
keyword tool uh you know we'll be going
over that information
in the upcoming training
but um
that's just a tip use long tail keywords
not short-term keywords and your
long-tail keywords you incorporate in
your blog post and you make it you don't
make it stick out you make sure that the
phrase is blended
hi okay keep that in mind
so for example every other chocolate
shop keywords might include milk
chocolate organic chocolate or natural
chocolate chocolate beers chocolate
bouquets deconstructed s'mores now what
about chocolate milk
if you are
if you are a
bakery and you offer chocolate
or as i said i'm sorry not bigger you
have a chocolate shop you say
how to make
milk chocolate or what are the
ingredients in milk chocolate or what
are the best types of milk chocolate or
how do you make organic chocolate
what is the best type of organic
chocolate
what is all natural chocolate
how do you make all natural chocolate
what are the best chocolate gifts
do people even buy chocolate gifts
chocolate bouquets what is a chocolate
bouquet how do you make a chocolate
bouquet
how to make
a chocolate bouquet for your spouse or
when is the best time to buy a chocolate
bouquet or deconstruct the s'mores what
are the s'mores
difference between deconstructed s'mores
and constructive s'mores i don't know
i'm just throwing stuff out there i want
you to get your mind jogging on the
types of keyword
phrases that you can use
and so you also have
your event listings because you need to
have events for business
right you know your online events will
be like online training different
contents contents that you you're doing
um what you're doing for your
pre-launches of your products
all types of
interactive things that you can do and
you know i'll give you more examples in
the training if you decide to
to join because you want more
information you want to learn so you can
grow your you can either grow your
business or grow your career or start a
new career
also holiday listings you know
you might i don't know what your
religious or
spiritual preference
preferences are
but i will say as a business owner you
have to follow the trends and
some trends fall inside holidays
so
if you are
you have to live up to that you know
what i'm saying
i'm sorry you you have you have to meet
your customers expectations
especially once you start generating a
loyal customer base and a loyal fan base
you have to keep up with joneses
you have to decide the type of content
you want to publish on each occasion
there are four formats formats of
content
text audio visual image
now get content produce intertwines all
of those
if you just if you if you're not
comfortable doing a video
find a video on your own and include it
in your blog post
you know make sure that it's relevant
put images in your blog post you know
add audios or
you know have have a podcast but make
sure that you are incorporating the
different formats of content so you can
engage the different types of reader
and audience because each person has
their own preference
you know i used to be a school teacher
one of the things that
that's heavily emphasized is
differentiation making sure that your
lessons are differentiated for each type
of learner
and in this case the each type of reader
would be
people would like to hear watch
read and see
and as i mentioned you merge these two
together to create a publishing schedule
in advance so you are never stuck every
day and you don't know what type of
content you want to write
the good the best thing to do
i like to plan my content out at least
12 weeks in advance i like to work in 90
day cycles
because
it's about short-term planning and
compartmentalizing and setting deadlines
and setting goals and so
what um i will do with you
if you're in my class is i will teach
you how to write a 90-day calendar
and i will share with you my 19-day
calendar
when you register
and
content and conversion points once your
content is planned it should be combined
with the appropriate conversion points
so for example if it's moore's day you
can upload an article on deconstructed
s'mores
you include a call to action with a link
to allow people to buy from your site
and have other offers such as shipping
buy one get one free and so on and so on
now
i'm going against the grain because what
i would do is something's totally
different
i will
upload the article on deconstructed
s'mores as long you know first i will
have a launch ter a long term keyword
i'm
a long-term keyword in my blog post and
not just deconstructed s'mores
and my call to action will be a link to
a capture a capture page instead of a
sales funnel the reason being is i just
mentioned to you
only 20 you only have 20 percent of
people that are loyal to you so only 20
percent of people are going to actually
buy when they first go to you to your um
your sales page but if you enter a call
to actually enter a lead magnet and you
give them
something such as a free shipping coupon
or buy one get one free if they buy and
they enter the email address
bam
so you give them the free offer they
have a discount code but it's going into
their email
instead of them going directly to the
site so once i go to the email you say
hey click this link below to get this
coupon to buy this and bam
you can get a sale and even if they
don't sell they don't buy right away
they're in your email list so what you
do when you have your blog post you
syndicate your blog post to your email
that is that from the people that you
captured on our website and and
once they enter the email you send them
the blog post hey i got a cool new blog
post on this topic that's relevant to
the topic that you already read and you
know go check it out you don't say that
but that's the concept that's the
concept behind it okay
so that's
adding a call to action and sending
people directly to your capture page
instead of going to your sales page is
how you are capturing the leads how
you're using email marketing and how you
are
reversing that 80 20 rule to get more to
create a more loyal customer base
because you're sitting you're sending
your blog post to
your list as well as you are syndicating
your blog post out okay
so we're we're we're doing two things
maybe three
um
first thing we'll do with writing a blog
post second thing that we're doing that
we're syndicating we're syndicating it
to on our social media networks and
we're syndicating to our list when we
syndicated syndicated across our social
media networks that we're affiliated
with we are driving
the purposes to driving traffic every
single day
now the purpose of having an email list
is to build your loyal fan base okay and
so you're doing those two
interchangeable things at the same time
with one simple blog post okay
and
um
in the next training we're going to talk
about email marketing and you know we
can get more into the functionality of
that
and we get more involved in it in my
training so let's move on let's move
forward
so um
look at
another example if there's national
toast and marshmallows days you can have
a social media contest and a call to
action for sharing for social sharing
but you have to have an active social
media account to do that the best place
to do something like that would be
facebook because
the functionalities are sick it's oh my
gosh it's amazing and you will love it
but you have to get on my training to
learn about it
and once you understand your goals you
tie them into your content and create
effective call to actions you lead to
the conversion point okay so
let's let's break it down and take a
step back long tail key keyword
answer it in your blog post you have a
call to action after
calls to action
and
once you have the call to action it's
inside your blog post you do two things
you send it to your list you send it to
your to the new people on social media
okay
um
i had a point forgot what it was but you
got my class yeah you learn more
so micro blogs another type of social
media what is a mic what is micro
blogging
micro blogging is sharing information
through micro blogs in the form of short
and frequent posts which are
usually a sentence long social based
follow be followed and shared
broadcasted share the broadcasted
followers the benefits of micro blogging
are
the quick seconds to publish their
accessible mobile on your mobile phone
or tablet or pc
they're very selective follow whom you
like and they're easy publishing you
connect to other platforms
you can micro blog through twitter
twitter is the leading micro blogging
site
it has large user base best choice of
apps great network integration and best
search functionality what do people
share on twitter it's probably what you
want to know
they share their locations they share
links they share questions and they
share comments
asked again any type of content you need
to have an established clear goal
starting a twitter campaign without
establishing clear goals will lead you
nowhere
sample goals for a twitter campaign are
build credibility to increase conversion
spark interest to create buzz and
buildings
listen to conversations to understand
what people like
and connect with people on a personal
level
you know although we are
living in a digital age
that um different technology has made it
so you're interacting
and you're able to make it personal it
helps with relationship
relationship marketing because
although they're behind
even now
more so because people are behind
computers they need them
they need to know that the source is
credible it's authentic
is
um
they're going to get what they invest in
they're going to have an roi
and they want to know like in
trust the people that they're working
with
and
social media gives you an opportunity to
do that on
a personal level and twitter does a
great job with that
why we retweets matter good question not
a big twitter user
may i just don't know anything about
twitter i syndicate on twitter
i do do that
every tweet is reposting someone else's
tweet
retweets allow ideas and informations to
be spread
the reason that it's spreading is
because when one person shares um clicks
something i mean posted something and
when people share it
everybody that they're friends with on
our social media site is gonna see and
twitter is fast
okay it's not like facebook facebook
doesn't move as fast
twitter twitter moves real fast
suppose you share an article on twitter
and one person retweets it
and again it goes out to the followers
and those followers can
retweet the article again if they like
it and so this multiply and effect helps
you get the maximum possible views and
expand your online reach
your twitter list
you're able to create topic based lists
so you include different users based on
industry interests or people
um
what this does is
you're able to track your conversions
and follow people
who um
follow people who are looking to target
within specific messages
you can build
credibility by recommending follows and
follow people without subscribing to
them
things you know to track on twitter
customer service
this is the biggest thing
proactively respond to customers
conversations okay
when people are
that's the point of social media so
let's break something down right because
businesses used to be ran on um
before the internet
was really big is referral and mouth to
mouth so people really
have a misconception that social media
has taken out a way no social media has
made it better because
they're still talking about the company
okay
and the reason is you your company needs
to be engaged in social media so you can
know when people are saying things about
you getting bad and you can respond to
them you know that's how that's that's
how you're that's one way you're
engaging with your customers
and it's really important to
um monitor because
when you get bad public bad comments you
need to hop on that because it can ruin
your reputation
see with our social media
or before social media you didn't know
what people were saying about you but
now
you can find out
okay it's about monitoring and tracking
and we go more into that inside of our
training
so you know this is general buzz and
shadow people talk
that's what we do we we've been
socializing since the beginning of time
since
diverse people on earth
okay the only thing that social media
has done
is giving you platforms to communicate
with people online okay
use it to your advantage you can connect
with so many more people online than you
can offline because it's global and
so the social sites that they're broken
down
social media networking sites you know
they have different groups and you can
communicate with different types of
people
and in the groups in the market that
you're interested in
send cements towards your brand
use tools to track how this change
like i said you know
you have to be able to respond when it's
bad or good so when people
are dissatisfied
you know
and they're ranting about it you can be
polite and apologize
and try to solve the problem
which builds trust within your markets
and trust with you because
you know hey things happen people we all
make mistakes
but if we can
acknowledge them and apologize for it
especially when somebody's being rude to
us
that's
that's a big person and that's bill's
good business
you can also track the impact on your
sales you can check how many people
respond to your tweets about discounts
offers you know
you want to monitor the monitor your um
your post and you can do that as well as
traffic and link generation
rather people share your your posts on
twitter twitter or other sites but
you know
they're able you're able to use twitter
to generate traffic so let me break that
down there are two ways people can share
information
on twitter if you have a twitter share
button on your blog or if you you post
your blog on twitter somebody retweets
it
okay
tools
site integration to make it easier for
people to tweet and retweet your content
develop desktop and mobile phone apps
you are able to
um use the different interfaces for each
it's convenient based who you're able to
schedule your content manage conversions
conversions and so on so on i don't use
twitter i don't know if they have a
scheduler inside of their um
their
page but i do know that there are
different tools that you can use to
schedule your um
your posts on twitter my favorite tool
is post planner and the reason postman
is my favorite tool is because they give
you all types of cool posts that you can
um read you know that you can share
and um they have different types of
posts
i'm not going to get into that but i
will in my class if you if you sign up
you search you want to find people topic
in their ideas um you can you need to
listen to what people talking about what
they're interested in so you can produce
the content you can you can be that
go-to person okay and that's what you
want to do online purpose of your
content is to educate people about your
your market and show people why you are
the expert and a lot of people should
work with you knowledge is key no one
wants to do business with someone that
doesn't know what they're talking about
like have you ever been into a store
and they can't help you because i didn't
know about the product you're like okay
well i'm leaving and i can answer your
question and you're like okay well i
don't want to give you my money because
you don't know what you're talking about
i know
i'm sorry i might be talking fast i know
i'm not the only person that's done that
like bad customer service if you don't
know about your product you're not
getting my money
i make when i buy stuff
i do it strategically i'm going to get
the best
if you can answer the questions that i
need to need answer i guess i'm like
shopping for like clothes or something
but
yeah i need to know my shoes and stuff
like if i'm looking for customer service
and you can't help me because you don't
know i'm done
and you should always have be able to
solve the problems even if they're not
inside the store the answers aren't
inside the store sorry
i talk too much sometimes so check the
time you spend on twitter based on
how new it is to your company
so minutes per day
15 minutes to follow 20 to less than 30
office share for 45 and engage with 60.
depending on where you are in this
timeline whether you're following
listening offering sharing or engaging
is how many minutes you should spend
each day
social networks there's all your social
channels
okay
now you're gonna be blown away by what
i'm getting ready to tell you because
i didn't realize
that social networks
and social media are not the same things
how social networking works
social networks allow you to choose who
to network with
you're able to access to extend networks
access to extend networks where you can
see how your connections are aging or
other
so i'm social media
allows you to monitor
who's engaging with you okay
and how to engage with those people
and you can broadcast to or retrieve
information from your network what that
means is you can broadcast your
information or you can get broadcasted
information from your network
and and all in one multi
sharing such as status updates private
messages
um you can share links to resources
websites media
the king
and the number one
social networking site is facebook
facebook is my baby i love facebook and
you're getting ready to find out why
it is socially focused mostly consumer
to consumer environment
it provides brands and businesses the
opportunity to connect with people and
build conversions
it has a larger largest user base
therefore provides greater exposure
facebook has over 1.5 billion
members interact daily is growing like
there are other social networking sites
that um are growing but facebook is the
biggest it's the largest and they're
always going to trump they're always
going to stay on top okay that's what
business is that's what business is
about
staying on top of your competitors and
people think that oh because these other
social networking networking sites
they're growing
so is facebook they're always going to
come out with something
something
extra
that you can't do that that site is
doing like you know twitter started with
periscope now they have live streaming
and go figure you have snapchat now they
have they have a they have a video
snapchat thing on for their live on
facebook like they're growing they're
always going to grow they are their
marketing is so
targeted target specific is so sexy and
amazing like it's just really going to
blow your mind but you
but
you know to get the in-depth i really
need you to
log into my training
and sign up and make sure that you click
the links over here to send me my videos
it has the largest user base therefore
provides great exposure i just had to
repeat that okay because
you just i need that to stick in your
head
it offers kind of
categorization tools to control views
um another big one is linkedin
linkedin rules and online business
networking space
so um
yeah so let's let's break some things
down
about linkedin
linkedin
is how
simply learn found me
okay
they they were
the recruiters were searching and
they
saw my profile and they connected with
me
and
it was on a popular assistant and it was
the best decision i've ever made because
this is the most amazing company i've
ever worked for and
as i'm building my own business i'm
having an opportunity to do what i love
i love teaching i love digital marketing
and
they found me on on linkedin it's a
business networking site okay so rather
you are taking this course because you
are looking to venture into this field
or you're already in marketing and you
need you need to stay abreast with the
new trends or you're looking to start
your business
uh start your own business in digital
marketing or you just you want to be
able to apply these things in digital
marketing network linkedin
linkedin is the networking site is i'm
sorry linkedin is a social networking
site that you go for your business
for b2b con b2b
okay
i mean you do also on social media
they're on facebook and other places but
this is the this is the go to let me
bring something down that i didn't share
with you each social media networking
site has its own purpose and that's what
linkedin is
it's like linkedin is like the place
where you put your
resume and you share your content
okay
it is much more than a dynamic resume or
online contract sites
it's about building
connections and
socializing with people in the different
groups and the areas of your
specialization okay it's a professional
networking site no
it provides inroads into corporate
networks through common connections hi
that's why i'm here
hosting this training with simply learn
because
i was networking well they were
networking i i
have to give credit to the creditors
dude they were networking
so what do people share people share
their updates the photos their links
their connections
okay
and why social networks matter
consumers tend to speak freely in social
media so marketers can search
through
consumers speak
why social network matters so a few
slides back i broke something down for
you i said so
i said
businesses started with
word of mouth
and referrals and what social media has
done is took that concept
and 10 times it
because people chat that's the point of
social media people to get on there and
talk with their friends and their
colleagues ship images pictures videos
whatever
okay
good marketers
they see that as a
place to research so you can see what
they're talking about and what their
preferences are in your market so you
can feel those needs and business you
are
you
in business you are a problem solver so
you have to be able to solve the
problems in the market
so in order to solve the problems in
your market you have to know what the
problems are what social media does is
give you a opportunity to find out what
they are and there are different texts
there are different tools and
tricks that we can do that you have to
join my classes and learn
they share endorsements help brands to
boost credibility and fine points of
commonalities and consumers now what you
want to do is you want to build that
brand you want people to boast about
your credibility and find points
to um
share some people buy right
that's why i say you need to have a um
capture page and a
conversion marketing funnel so people
can get into your
email list so you can um
send them your blog post and you also
syndicate your blog across social
different social networking sites okay
so um again your blog has to be good
relevant talk
get relevant
content and so the more content that you
produce in your marketing the more
relevant it is the more good it is
you're going to attract a bigger bigger
reader you'll get new people in
in your list and you're keeping your
your nurture your current your the
people that's already on the list
and so those people are already on your
list they become your fans they become
come your raving loyal fan to help boost
your credibility
unlike real world
word-of-mouth interaction social media
conversations or shares result in
immediate action by the view by viewers
which means that rather they're talking
good or bad about you
however many friends they have they're
going to see it right they have 500
friends 5 000 friends
and they share something good or bad
about your company those people are
going to see it
and regardless of what it is you need to
be able to control that
especially if it's bad
because you don't you don't want to get
a bad reputation if you already want to
do it especially if it's good because it
boosts you so it's a it's a hand in hand
okay but it's only hand in hand if
you're using social networking sites
okay
understanding facebook
as i said facebook is my baby
facebook has three functions
congregations conversations and
publications congregation people bring
people together
so
let me share something
you can create your own private group
okay
and you can it can be a free group or
you can have have it something with a
membership plan that you have on your
site and people pay um
pay and they can join join your group or
you can actually have both okay
you have you have a community for just
people that are on your list and you
have a community for people that buy
your products so you can give them more
hands on assistance and give them top
notch no no deals and stuff
but
facebook allows you to do that you can
have as many groups as you want
i have tons of them and i'll show you
some of my groups now i will admit um
let's give you a little bit of
background about myself when i started
in digital marketing i started
as a uh internet marketer
and i was an affiliate of two different
companies
and
i created different niche groups for for
that
now i haven't actually been active in
all of them
none of them i'm not going to lie to you
recently but in my training i will show
you what the groups are and i will show
you how to create a group you can also
have conversations with people you have
some conversations with people to post
to the post that you you post or through
engaging in other fan pages and um
you know just or group pages and just
networking with people
and publication you're allowed to share
your thoughts with others you know
through your posts you can produce
visual audio
yes there is an audio component i i will
give you my secret in my class so don't
even ask me that
um videos images
okay
all types of publications that you can
share and also your advertisements but
you should only advertise ten percent of
your content so like on average you can
commonality you should schedule five or
seven posts a day with one of those
posts being
a buy me post okay
but we'll get into that later in my
class
you want to build up presents on
facebook your presence is your brand
then people know that you exist now i
know you like ginger well if i have a
blog why do i need this your your blog
is your home facebook is his grandma
house or your boyfriend or girlfriend
house or your best friend house a second
home the second home that you go to
you know when you you just outside your
home and you know you just go there you
come comfortable and do the thing that
you normally do at your own housing
shoes or go in the kitchen you know make
yourself some food if you gotta go
you know you have to go
to the bathroom and go off the bed you
have to be number two and you're like oh
i'm out i don't want to use it at the
house but you know you got this person
house and you got comfortable enough to
do it so facebook is your second home i
said that all that to get you
drum it in your
head nail it
home number one is your blog hold number
two is facebook other social media sites
you use to syndicate yours your content
and you're on there when people interact
with you and they they
they you know talk about your business
and they tag you with something
okay but you build your second presence
on facebook because of the engagement
that you're able to do because you're
able to create these groups because
you're able to do so many different
things on facebook and i'm going to
share with you now to build a
build a presence on facebook
there are five options available to
create
oh
build a friend on facebook there are
five options available to create a
presence on facebook which includes
your personal profiles individuals users
home page on facebook okay this is your
personal page this is where you connect
with your friends and you you know you
share all your all the little cute
cutesy lucy videos you know and
you can laugh at all this stupid stuff
and you also share about your business
if need be but i wouldn't really
recommend it unless it's like a blog
post
facebook pages yourself they're showing
home of a business on facebook if you
have you're using facebook for marketing
you have to have a page you don't post
about your business on your profile you
can post engaging
stuff
like humorous emotional thought provoke
content you know on your page but you
don't advertise your business on your
page you can advertise your blog posting
page but don't advertise your business
on your page that's not what it's for
facebook groups they're not not owned by
anyone
gathering of like-mind users
so basically you know you can have as i
mentioned you have free groups you have
a private membership and interact with
people on facebook and you know i can
teach you the difference between
between the two in the upcoming training
um
you really want to use groups
for your your companies you know going
back to the chocolate shop you know you
can have a have a community of people
that
like to buy your product you have
community people that want to learn that
want to learn how to make chocolate
okay
coaching and consulting is is hot and
you need to incorporate it in your
business
another topic different day just a
little bit ad-libbed on my brain
facebook
aggravates
facebook aggregates conversion
community facebook aggregates
conversation around
different
topics okay
as i mentioned it's so it's so
neo-specific you have a group for
everything
and so you can join a group or whatever
whatever markets you're interested in
rather it's personal or business related
and you can talk to people around those
topics
and places
they have a physical
dedicated
section
on their posts for you to check in to a
business
okay
and you want people to do that for your
business
find fans and build connections on
facebook so you're trying to figure out
how to do that so you have your existing
customers
you yeah website visitors
other social sites word of mouth on
facebook and paid facebook ads so let me
let's break this down
so your existing customers
you let them you know let them know hey
i got a facebook you sent out an email
and say hey i just found a facebook page
or when people opt into your email
and your welcome page you say hey make
sure you check out my fan page you put
the link in the email
you have website visitors you can have a
link on on your
social media sharing for people to share
on facebook over there you can have it
in your signature connect with me on
facebook
um you offer incentive and exclusive
content
or you know vice versa word of mouth on
facebook this is big as i just mentioned
that um
the people talk facebook is
is a chatting community
and so
you can share your everything on
facebook okay it's your second home
and you can also link to your other
social networking sites such as twitter
youtube or pinterest to also raise a new
engagement and instagram
the biggest and the best way to build
connection on facebook is to
use paid facebook advertisements because
you can actually
with um
when you have a target market
now let me just give you that i'm going
to break something down to you real
quick another big tip that i really do i
just learned this tip a couple of weeks
ago
when i was doing research to finish up
my ebook
um
okay
you have your mainstream market which is
the industry that you're in and then you
have different target markets or
different niche markets and the more
niche markets you have
the more people that you're able to
reach so you know have you ever heard of
people say oh well my business for
everybody is not for everybody you might
have to have
50 niches that you can target
target those niches by all means
but don't target them in the same way
each niche has to be talked to in their
own language so what facebook allows you
to do is create
um targeted ads based off demographic
geographic psychological and behavioral
um
demographics okay based on their lives
their interests but they do they spend
their money how much they make where
they live
all types of things and the soul is so
so so sexy but the point of doing this
is you know once you create your
customer avatar which is the person who
is your ideal customer you can create
one ad directly to that person
you can also create custom audiences
or run
um do
um
new copycat audiences so like
simply learn
if they did um
an ad would be for
like a business school or a marketing
school
they can create an ad targeted
to people that like a specific school
and say they you know and target them
as i have mentioned facebook's your
second home it allows you to plan
interactions through quizzes and games
include multimedia encourage discussions
ideas and interests and increase
conversions through discounts and offers
the importance of your news feed your
new fee is the core of your facebook
interactions
it gives you maximum reason and limited
exposure through message broadcast
it establishes credibility as people
connected to your brand may share their
experience with their connections
facebook news feed is constantly
updating increasing impressions
and
most interactions with the target
audience occurs to the newsfeed less
than 10 people less than one percent of
people check posts on the page itself 99
see those posts where it shows up in
their newsfeed and so what facebook um
as allows you to do is when you have a
high number of people in your um
that like your community you can
actually run an ad to make sure that the
99 percent of those people show up it um
your post shows up in their newsfeed
your interactions and exposures increase
as you show up more in the news feed and
also another thing that you do is um
create
you share you create engaging content so
more people want to interact and i have
some other tips that i can show you but
you have to join my class
the viral nature of facebook is shares
times friends
means
you have
more
users
so if somebody shares something if you
get 100 shares and each 100 person has
135 friends that means that that share
is being shared with 135 people
that's that's how things go viral when
people when you friends of friends share
stuff okay
and the reason they do that is because
their information is engaging and it's
captivating
facebook ads with ads with a news feed
appear like regular updates that are
more likely to be noticed
example a company selling selling
wedding gowns the wedding boutique may
be interested in reaching out to future
brides rather rather than fathers at the
briars
so um
based off of
people liking different bridal
registries they're able to um
create a customized audience
selling it to people that like those
that like those pages okay
so you narrow down your audience by
setting criteria such as age gender
relationships status and so on and
target the right people to gain
followers exposure and momentum momentum
on social media social media so like
getting back to the writing exam with
somebody like david's bridal you can
create a
if you you're
say you have a wedding company
you live in baltimore maryland
you can create
a custom audience of people that like
david bridle that live in maryland
between
25 and 45 that's engaged
simple that means that your ad will show
up in that target markets um
news feed
so sexy and sick huh
media sharing sites
other media statistics in a month
americans alone watch 46.7 billion
online videos which is equivalent to six
hours of video content
in a week fifty percent of people online
watch business related videos
time spent online 33 is watching videos
online
and
while 80
watch a video on somebody's website and
only 20 will read the content so what
does this mean going back to your blog
your home on the internet remember i
told you that you can produce four types
of content audio visual video
and
in text
you create a video and you post a video
on your website
now as you
know typically with the videos that i
create you can see my face now this
particular one i'm using something
called a share screen and there are
different um
different software that you can use to
make videos where you're sharing your
screen but the free one that i love is
called um screen o matic
and you you can just do a google search
for it screen dot screen dash o
dash matic
it's free to use but they also have a
paid version where you spend 15 dollars
a month i mean 15 a year and you can get
access to to make edit the editor and
stuff
um
you know that's just this is one little
tool that you can use if you you know
you're scared to show your face on video
you can do a screen sharing and there
are different ways that you can um
create different videos like you can
make animated videos
through different softwares like animal
enemies or
majestical i think that's the name of i
don't remember but um
yeah videos are hot they're popular and
they're a way that you engage and
connect with your audience with a real
life perspective
people absorb the same information
that's the time where photos
and videos are used another good photo
for you to use is something called an
infographic it's just it's like a big
chart that has different little pictures
on it that you can add and um you break
down information or like if you want to
do a t-chart or something it's like
really cool and you can go to canva
cava.com to create your own um
images so just real quick i'm gonna say
this the two softwares again that you
can use it's granomatic
and
camera you can also use
google hangouts
or um facebook live broadcast and do a
um powerpoint just to give you know just
different tools that you that you can
use
online media statistics example the
impact of media content on viewer action
after watching a video
so let's look at this video and we're
talking about the apple watch
percent of you is purchased the future
product
52 of customers found it easier to make
purchase decisions related to the
product
26 percent of internet users
look for more information on the product
and 75 percent of users
visited a moderator's website for
information about that brand and this is
why it's important for you to create
content about your products okay just
stuff like this
the impact of media content on viewer
action after watching an ad video web
pages with videos are 50 times more
likely to appear
as the first two search result pages of
the search engine
and landing pages with videos see an
increase of eighty percent
in conversion rate so that means that on
your your web your capture page your
landing page where people go to get your
your free offer
and set it like i said instead of you
sending them to your sales page you send
them this they capture their information
to get in your database so you can they
can start building a loyal following
when you have a video on the landing
page it increases 86 in conversion
understanding youtube listen
i have a lovely relationship with
youtube but the more i find out about
youtube the more i'm in love with
youtube have a love hate relationship
with youtube because i had one of my
channels my first channel shut down and
i'll produce some killer content
youtube is a top sharing network that
provides a platform for uploading
sharing and viewing video content
and the average weekend equivalent of
242 000 fallen hollywood movies is
uploaded on youtube
benefits of youtube for your business
let me be let me before i even go
further
google youtube and facebook are the
largest traffic sites
youtube is
awesome
okay
you can build video content with
information such as product reviews
demonstration demonstrations live
trainings
um
webinars such as this one
you always do a lot of broadcasting do
hangouts google hangouts
youtube's are now incorporated into
universal search
and you can also like i said
the content you um when you write a blog
post you can do a quick video and you
can have a cta to your blog post of that
or you know
you could highlight some of the key
points and from your blog post but in
the video i'm like hey check out my blog
post here and you're driving traffic you
know you can still put relevant
information you also put the youtube
video on your blog post
you can share it on different
environments
just as you have the ability to embed
content other people can also take your
content embed it on their websites and
blog so if you're writing a blog post if
you don't have a video and you want to
find something relevant you can always
go to youtube and find that video and
embed it on your in your blog post which
actually is also good for your rating
ratings okay because google likes an
information to share so it's like an
inbound linking robots they know like
hey
you know just it just makes you look
better because you're you you're adding
credits okay because you're resourceful
you know blog post is like writing a
little short
paper for college you just have to you
and then you have to have like three
references and youtube is just a
reference reference but you want to make
sure that the information is relevant
okay that's good
you share on various social media
channels
you can directly share video content on
facebook twitter tumblr and others
social media channels for it to go viral
understanding pinterest i don't know too
much about pinterest but i do know it's
a great site and i also have a pinterest
um page so a social media channel that
allows people to see save and share
images it's huge like
i don't um
i syndicate my content on it and
i do know that you can have different um
boards per topic and they also have a
business page now but other than that i
don't know too much about it
so i'm not going to have too much app ad
lib
besides you know share your content
there because it's hot as it's a big
site is that people at and you you know
you you put the image that you have in
your blog post on pinterest and a little
extra except for your blog and with a
call to action you have to learn more
click these blog posts and then click
the blog post and i go to your blog
for from being on this site pinterest
has moved to becoming a mainstream ideas
and media sharing site
pinterest
took the idea of bookmarks and
socialized it in a visual manner which
is hides
benefits of pinterest
pinterest is a visual archive of
articles information resources which is
easy to go through and share with others
with a whole world of content and idea
discovery it gives brands a great
opportunity to give their message out in
front of people
pinterest is set content segmented
which you know i was talking about the
pins
the pins or the boards
i think i said boards but it's actually
called a pen
you have the ability to set up topical
boards and your followers send select
specific topics to receive in their news
feed
let's look at some stats of an average
pin
an average pin drives two times two
visits and six page views to a website
the average pen is worth 78 cents
in sales
the average payment receives repins and
pinterest is considered a traffic
hashtag producer
the average pen is roughly 100 times
more
viral than an average tweet wow
marketing on pinterest has latest latent
results as people make their awesome
decision by researching gathering ideas
and gathering examples for instance half
of the visitors occurred three months
after the time it was originally pinned
half of the orders
occurred two months after the visits so
listen the power of blogging and email
marketing
i might about to make the connection
when you write the pin
you have your blog post
and in the blog post you have your call
to action about
you know check this out to get more
information give them a freebie
in there throughout the email marketing
process is when you're doing a selling
each more each product that you have
should have this old marketing funnel
okay that's just to let you know
and so because
um
organic traffic is something that's
built over time it's not something that
you generate right away we want more
traffic right away you use paid methods
okay and so um
your blog is your home is never going to
go nowhere so you know when you make
these pizzas the information sitting
there although you know statistically
proven it takes a lot more time but once
it's out there is out there like you can
have content on your website for years
to come my first blog that i may use
what you got
is for on wordpress it is still there
and that was seven years ago
so you know as long as you
you keep it and you maintain it you will
always have this what this website
which means that your products will
always be out there so if somebody do a
search for it for it four years from now
and you have that content out there they
can still go back to your blog
this fyi
pinterest versus facebook
ha
pinterest average time spent 90 minutes
a month facebook every time i spend
seven hours a month
some people spend seven hours a day i
think i'm joking
viewed as a starting point facebook for
pinterest is
viewed as a starting point facebook is
viewed as a destination
platform to ideas and aspirations
you know people they're like oh this is
my wish list this is what i might want
versus facebook connect share and have
conversations
people
visit pinterest to read and devour
content people
go to facebook to stay and engage
pinterest is the place to attract fans
and get new exposures and drive drive
people drive traffic and facebook is
where you engage with your fans
strength of pinterest
low back low barriers entry virtually no
development required minimum minimal
training needed
impressive traffic potential one of the
top 10 traffic referrers across the web
provides a continued traffic bump
group retention rate a strong
possibility to get increased followers
equal impact potential even small
followers can score big pins use lots of
exposures and they have a wide open
terms of service no restrictions on
engaging with followers and use creative
and unique ways to leverage pinterest
instagram
i'm
it's okay i haven't i haven't became a
full ig fan yet but i have a few pages
actually audrey is hot i'm not even
gonna lie
it's a photo sharing version of twitter
that is focused on pictures and
experience sharing so instagram moves
just as fast as twitter okay
instagram is owned by facebook you can
actually run ads on instagram through
your facebook through your facebook ads
that's more in-depth training that you
will get if you sign up for my training
make sure you sign up
the average user spends 257 a month on
instagram i did not know that
what i mean hours that is
let's see
plus 120
is 240. so that's four hours and 17
minutes a month
the average user outside the united
states shares 60 of the
photographic content on instagram
and 83 of pictures that are associated
with a hashtag hashtags makes it easier
for users to follow conversations and
topics across the board hashtags are
used for research purposes okay when
you're looking to um
know your content you want to use use
instagram you do a hashtag search to
find out
what's um
what's trending what people talking
about okay that's why you use hashtags
that's the purpose of hashtags and
just for giggles and so you know i can
help you out further in my training i'll
go over that a little bit more
around 20 million active users log into
instagram
regularly
pictures that have faces are 38
more likely to get likes listen people
don't put logos for your profile
pictures don't put little cute pictures
or whatever you need to have a picture
of your face it's social media okay
people want to engage with you
they want to feel like you're credible
you're not credible if you don't have
your face on the page
pictures have pictures that have faces
are 32
more likely to generate comments
around 35
million selfies have been posted on
instagram since it was started
instagram is all about people and
personalities and as a brand you should
identify what works on instagram and how
your brand fits in you build your brand
you push your product and you use fan
generator content and you also have your
your call to action you have your link
now there there are
tricks to using
those links because i don't think you
can put links inside the post like you
can have a link to your capture page on
your
on your um on your page and so in your
in the content with your picture you can
say hey click the link in the bio
so when you're building your brand you
share behind the scenes information you
show how the products are uses the key
to oh
facebook has videos that you can shoot
up to like one minute now and i think
they also have a live streaming fixture
now
i'm not mistaken you push your product
showcase new items and show products
being used at use identify traffic
drivers
use fan generated content hold contests
use hashtags and make it an event people
love to be engaged okay
um
i can give you a listing of of different
contests in my class but you have to
sign up and make sure that you know
like i said make sure you sign you click
the link to subscribe to something learn
channel and there's going to be a link
somewhere at the bottom that's going to
have information about simply learn
the upcoming trainings for you just make
sure that you
click
that and use hashtags to make it easy
for people to discover and participate
in your campaigns
point to remember
your real life pictures were better than
infographic quotes and instructive
graphics test different content types to
see which one gets the best response
action set with instagram will help you
reach your goals and how you can measure
them
um
just my side note i think using a
combination
would be good you can't you cannot post
an infographic because it is too big
but there are ways that you can post
larger pictures but i'm not getting into
that
quotes everybody loved quote pictures
let's make sure that it's relevant or
you know people people like that stuff
social review sites
huh br reviews such as brick and mortar
service providers travel and destination
product entertainment
um your brick and mortar
businesses are like restaurants shopping
centers sport things and so on
and you know people can write reviews on
you through like yelp and grubhub
if you're connecting on the side and
also write reviews for you
on your on your facebook fan page
if your service provides you home health
care housekeeping replacements and so on
you know you can sign up with angie's
list
as if you're doing travel and
destination you know
use tripadvisor
people um
you know you connect with tourists have
information about food their stay and so
on they'll talk about you if you have
you have a physical or digital product
you'll be on amazon or says and that
type of product that sells and the pros
and cons of the products and so on
and entertainment
you know such as movies music tv shows
and so on you can write reviews about it
so leveraging leveraging social views
while using social review sites you must
identify what type of review sites apply
to your business claim your listing if
possible to ensure that your information
is up to date make use of free marketing
opportunities
on these sites provide special deals to
people when they check in use free tools
to monitor common conversations and
vision review sites often to read and
respond
visit review sites often to read and
respond to your reviews it allows you to
look for patterns as they feel a great
as they get a feel of your overall
sentiments towards your brand
so let's look at some examples example
if you're running a restaurant
okay
by listening to conversation you have an
opportunity to know what it is that
people like or don't like so let me
share with you the power of social media
okay
there's a restaurant that was um opened
in the name
the neighborhood i grew up in as a child
that i went to with my cousin
and we had the most
horrible
horrific hideous
experience
so
i'm not a review people
but i was so disappointed
and offended
how i was treated i just had to go i had
to let them know
so they have a facebook page and i went
to their their website and i wrote a
review
and i was contacted i wrote a review and
i also emailed them
and i was offered to give be given a
free meal if i decided to come back but
i never went back
but my point of sharing this this with
you is because
i'm not the only person that had bad
reviews about the company they like had
half bad um half bad half good
and so without them having those reviews
on their facebook page they wouldn't
know what people were talking about
how how people felt about them
so
right you know even when you're you have
people that write good reviews you need
to say oh you know i am so happy you had
such a fantastic experience you know you
can offer them as some type of little
deal
you know just to interact you drive
people back people like to feel valued
you have to do that in business
business is about relationships and you
have to nurture and take care of those
relationships
based on conversations you know you know
what changes need to be made to meet
your customers needs
every admin is appropriate it's always
appropriate to react
it needs to ensure that you're learning
to react different types of customer
feedback
so rather is
when it says neutral is facebook valid
yes positive quality yes
and you can finally watch the
conversation
more trolls raging
crazies
isn't that
oh i'm sorry let me start over
you need to ensure that you are learning
to react to different types of customer
feedback
you have
five types of customer feedback neutral
more trolls raging crazies
misunderstanding and accurate
information raving praise specific
compliments and negative experience with
details
because i'm a customer oriented person i
believe that it's always valid to
address issues
but um
according to the
chart when it's neutral give positive
feedback yes
when people are raging crazy
the feedback isn't valid and the quality
of the feedback is negative you just
watch the conversation i don't think you
should just watch the conversation
i think you should
tell the person that
that you're sorry that they had a bad
experience and find out
find out
what can be done
to make that person better
and oh now most times you know they
might say no or no it might not even
change their view about you but the
reason i'm saying that you need to
address it is so other people that see
the reviews
there they see how
how you positively handle a bad
situation and that makes you more credit
credible
when your
misunderstandings will have enacted
information the same thing
you want to clarify it before it spreads
but you also want to
make the inaccurate information after it
raving praising specific compliments
yes it's valid feedback it is positive
and of course you say thank you to your
customers and i think that in good faith
you know you can offer them some type of
discount or some type of freebie
just to make you look good
it's about persona personal perspective
that people have about you negative
experience with specific details
feedback is positive yes the quality no
you recite this situation and thank them
for sharing
so we're going to end
our
introduction to social media foundation
here
i hope that you subscribe to the channel
and i hope to see you in my upcoming
class this is jennifer signing out for
selfie learn take care
you